et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
saradora dit bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau merci d'être là vous êtes
journaliste et auteur vous êtes Franco
iranienne vous êtes lauréate du prix de
la laïcité que vous avez obtenue au nom
des femmes iraniennes c'était en 2018
vous suivez bien sûr à titre personnel
et professionnel j'imagine ce qui se
passe en Iran depuis le 16 septembre
dernier bien avant bien sûr mais
particulièrement depuis le 16 septembre
dernier la mort de Marsa à minuit le
mouvement de protestation que sont décès
en détention a provoquer est entré dans
sa septième semaine
quels sont d'abord vos nouvelles
personnelles diront les nouvelles
personnels c'est les nouvelles que tous
les Iraniens de l'extérieur on a
beaucoup plus de nouvelles je pense que
les Iraniennes l'intérieur parce que il
y a ces problèmes de coupure d'Internet
et tout quoi que
les Iraniens sont quand même malins ils
arrivent à sortir des images des images
de ce qui se passe et des manifestations
c'est pour ça que tous les Iraniens sont
devenus des journalistes citoyens c'est
grâce à eux qu'on a des images ce ne
sont pas des images
de la télévision d'État avant c'était
aussi le problème c'est que on ne savait
pas vraiment ce qui se passait avant Tik
Tok avant Instagram avant les réseaux
sociaux d'ailleurs c'est la différence
aussi avec 2009 c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
y a toutes ces images qui sont sorties
je pense que c'est
d'abord on a une bonne visibilité de ce
qui se passe en Iran évidemment on a un
intérêt quand on est d'origine iranienne
on regarde plus attentivement mais je
pense aussi que c'est très intéressant
pour les pays occidentaux
intéressants et embarrassant pourquoi
parce que le régime islamique c'est bien
comment il traite les gens c'est bien
qu'il tue qu'il viole qu'il oppriment et
qu'il supprime la liberté depuis 43 ans
ça ils sont au courant ils savent ce qui
est compliqué pour les pays
démocratiques c'est d'être aujourd'hui
face à ces images qui sont sorties
aujourd'hui plus personne ne peut dire
ah mais on ne savait pas ah non mais
nous on avait vu que des femmes en
tchador marcher sur le drapeau américain
ah c'est pas ça ben non c'est pas ça et
savent là aujourd'hui
collaborer collaborer c'est le nom
pardon c'est le verbe qui convient avec
ce régime qui tue aujourd'hui des jeunes
des femmes des étudiants qui tuent
véritablement je veux dire c'est pas une
image avant on pouvait imaginer que
voilà tu es où
faire taire c'était une image c'était un
synonyme une métaphore ça l'est pas il
tue vraiment à balle réel les gens quand
on est témoin de ça et qu'on continue à
soutenir ce régime soutenir ça veut dire
faire encore des affaires être encore en
négociation se dire oui mais attendez on
discute peut-être le dossier sensible
qui est le dossier nucléaire je dois
rappeler le sentiment des Iraniens qui
est il n'y a pas de dossier nucléaire
s'il n'y a pas de Mola voilà on va y
revenir dans un instant mais je voudrais
qu'on compare un peu de cette de cette
révolte vous êtes l'une de celle
d'ailleurs qui révolution depuis
quasiment le début du mouvement est-ce
que vous avez l'impression
je trouve un moment de bascule en ce
sens qu'on est à peu près dans les 40
jours quoi après la mort c'est 40 jours
important après la mort de plusieurs
figures de la contestation parallèlement
la contestation et on parlait de ces
procès publics qui vont avoir lieu cette
semaine et monter d'un cran vous parliez
de ses tirs à balles réelles qui ont eu
lieu dans plusieurs universités est-ce
qu'il y a quelque chose là qui peut
basculer d'un côté ou de l'autre ce qui
peut faire basculer je pense très
sincèrement maintenant c'est le
l'implication
et l'alliance des pays occidentaux
d'abord avec le peuple iranien
véritablement ça veut dire rappeler les
ambassadeurs renvoyer les diplomates et
que qu'on soit très clair que les pays
occidentaux soient très clairs avec leur
rapport soit on choisit le régime soit
on choisit le peuple on peut pas
simplement soutenir avec des mots en
disant les femmes iraniennes vous êtes
vraiment formidables on est vraiment
admiratif de tout ce que vous faites en
revanche on continue à faire des
affaires avec eux en revanche on
continue à faire à négocier avec avec ce
régime là ce n'est pas possible de faire
les deux j'entends vous savez
Emmanuel Macron notre président qui dit
nous regardons attentivement ce qui se
passe mais vous savez combien de temps
depuis combien de temps les Iraniens
entendent ça de tous les chefs d'État
nous regardons attentivement mais
combien de temps vous allez regarder ce
qui se passe c'est terrible c'est
terrible de regarder de ne rien faire
parce que voilà maintenant aujourd'hui
vous voyez ce qui se passe donc
maintenant il faut plus regarder il faut
être dans l'action ce peut faire
basculer aussi c'est que l'armée se
mette du côté du peuple et là ils
viennent de d'augmenter de 50% le
salaire des soldats c'est vous dire que
ils sont en train de tout faire pour
essayer de tuer encore plus de gens pour
essayer d'éliminer le plus d'opposants
possible sauf que c'est quoi
l'opposition en Iran on dit ce sont les
jeunes et les femmes mais je suis désolé
mais les jeunes et les femmes en Iran
c'est 80% de la population certains
iraniens craignent alors est-ce que
c'est à cause de la répression qui
grandit est-ce que c'est précisément à
cause de du manque de relais
international on va on va y revenir que
le mouvement s'essouffle est-ce que
c'est votre inquiétude
je ne pense pas que le mouvement va
s'essouffler je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que
la jeunesse aujourd'hui qui est dans la
rue
c'est pas une jeunesse à qui le
gouvernement le régime islamique peut
reprocher d'être le pur produit d'Israël
ou des États-Unis de l'ennemi vous voyez
ce sont des enfants qui sont nés sous
cette révolution ils n'ont pas encore 20
ans vous voyez donc aujourd'hui cette
révolution va passer souffler ses
enfants là non connu que ça donc en
revanche il y a les réseaux sociaux
cette fois-ci les réseaux sociaux sont
de notre côté donc la révolution ne peut
pas en Iran à l'intérieur s'essouffler
et c'est un analyste qui disait très
justement que c'est le premier moteur ce
sont les Iraniens de l'intérieur la
jeunesse de l'Intérieur qui est en train
de de manifester de faire sa révolution
le deuxième moteur ce sont les Iraniens
de l'extérieur vous savez il faut
reconnaître aussi une chose
nous les Iraniens de l'extérieur nous
avons été nous-mêmes extrêmement mou
pendant ces années nous avons subi et
laisser faire pendant des années
pourquoi parce que nous aussi finalement
on était en se disait oui mais je vais
pas je vais pas parler devant les
caméras ou prendre la parole parce que
sinon je peux pas retourner en Iran
sinon je pourrai pas faire ci ou pas
faire mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire je
veux dire qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
face au courage de ces femmes là la
moindre des choses c'est prendre la
parole la moindre des choses c'est de
dire et rapporter leur voix quand on est
capable de le faire donc si ça
s'essouffle en Iran les Iraniens de
l'extérieur de l'extérieur seront là
pour non seulement manifester auprès
leur sympathie et leur alliance avec ces
jeunes là mais aussi pour rappeler
à leur pays démocratique dans lequel
nous vivons nous aux Iraniens des
États-Unis d'Angleterre de Canada de
France on leur rappelle aussi à nos
gouvernements ici attention ne faites
pas l'erreur soyez cette fois-ci au
moins du bon côté de l'histoire alors
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'est-ce qui ferait
selon vous pour parler de la France qui
est votre votre copine qu'est-ce qui
ferait que la France demain arrêterait
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure de
dire on vous regarde on vous observe on
soutient par les mots mais passerez à
quelque chose de ne plus concret
rappeler l'ambassadeur
arrêter le dossier nucléaire qui n'est
pas un dossier c'est un dossier
complètement irréel sur lequel ça fait
30 ans je veux dire si ce dossier devait
arriver quelque part il aurait déjà
abouti vous voyez donc c'est un dossier
en fait qui permet qui est au milieu de
l'Iran de la France des États-Unis et du
reste du monde en disant non non là on
est en train de scier on est en train de
négocier un dossier nucléaire on ne peut
pas trop les attaquer là on est en train
de se cacherait pour ne pas assumer
évidemment et là aujourd'hui parce que
je vais vous dire ça n'arrange personne
que l'Iran devienne démocratique que
l'Iran devienne un pays fort c'est
toujours plus facile de négocier tout à
la baisse avec un pays à problème en
disant vous savez vous n'êtes pas
exemplaire on vous méprise mais on va
vous mépriser officiellement mais
officieusement on va faire des affaires
ça n'arrange personne qu'aujourd'hui
l'Iran devienne démocratiques la seule
chose c'est que je vais vous dire se
réveiller après 43 ans après avoir subi
pendant 43 ans ce régime barbare c'est
que aujourd'hui c'est cette population
intérieure et extérieure que sont les
Iraniens encore une fois les Iraniens de
l'extérieur ne se sont sentis moi je me
sens française mes amis qui sont aux
États-Unis se sentent américaines mais
on n'a jamais arrêté de se sentir
iranien cette fois-ci plus personne ne
va plier en abandonnera pas même si en
Iran les jeunes ont un coup de mou nous
n'abandonnerons pas cette fois-ci
d'autant qu'il y a donc il y a un débat
surestis s'agit d'une révolte d'une
révolution quelque part une révolution
voilà il y a des choses qu'il ne
souffriront aujourd'hui on a
l'impression d'aucun retour en arrière
quand on voit ces femmes marcher à
Téhéran sans voile est-ce qu'elle le
remettront un jour est-ce quand on voit
ces femmes qui font de la moto ce qui
est interdit je crois en Iran quand on
est une femme est-ce que voilà on sent
qu'il y a quelque chose quand même qui
est qui est presque à qui quoi à quel
prix mais là il y aura pas de il y aura
pas de retour en arrière de façon
générale il y aura pas de retour en
arrière possible pourquoi parce que si
ces là
se sentent abandonnés on imagine le pire
scénario
la population iranienne intérieure
aujourd'hui ces jeunes sont abandonnés
par la scène internationale par les
Iraniens de l'extérieur
ont eu encore plus on va exécuter pour
donner l'exemple et pour pour que les
les étudiants et les jeunes arrêtent de
venir dans la rue ils vont faire des
exécutions publiques c'est ce qui est
prévu là vous voyez c'est terrible
des témoins de ça et de se dire non là
on réfléchit à ce qui est l'opportunité
pour nous non là c'est pas possible donc
ce qui se passe en Iran aujourd'hui
c'est un point de non-retours pour ces
jeunes là ça c'est sûr en revanche il y
aura toujours des femmes voilées il y
aura toujours bien sûr mais
celles qui ont enlevé le voile celles
qui sont allés dans la rue et qui se
tiennent devant les forces par un
militaire les Gardiens de la Révolution
les bassidy celle qui se tiennent devant
celle-là jamais elle ne
[Musique]
un peuple qui est en train de mourir
vraiment il y a du sang qui coule de des
mains de ces mots-là et à chaque fois
que quelqu'un
ose prononcer le mot liberté il risque
de se prendre une balle dans la tête
qu'est-ce que c'est je vais dire
imaginez ça en français et je comprends
en tant que française que on ne
s'imagine pas exactement ce que c'est de
vouloir la liberté pas de vélo pas le
droit de faire du jogging avec un
leggings pas le droit de montrer les
chevilles pas le droit de se regarder se
tenir la main pas le droit à rien pas le
droit de chanter pas le droit de danser
rien n'est possible rien n'est possible
vous savez vous allez en Iran vous êtes
en train de faire franco-iranienne je
vais en Iran je suis en train de faire
la queue pour aller à la pharmacie il y
a un type qui passe et qui passe devant
tout le monde et en fait tout le monde
est habitué à ça ce n'est pas possible
alors on a supporté personne s'habitue
on a supporté pendant 43 ans aujourd'hui
on ne supportera plus ni à l'intérieur
ni à l'extérieur
on a entendu votre propos merci
infiniment merci bienvenue ce matin on
aurait pu en parler j'avais encore
beaucoup de questions à vous poser
saradorak
merci infiniment d'être venu sur ce
plateau